et bonjour à tous salut comment vas-tu
salut ça va très bien merci bonsoir tout
le monde
bonsoir à tous Alors j'espère que ton
micro marche bien petit problème
peut-être de micro Sami alors dites-nous
sur le chat si jamais il y a un petit
problème avec Samy mais normalement ça
va le faire
je pense que ça devrait être bon alors
du coup pour le match d'aujourd'hui donc
on a les Gotham Knights contre les
Californie contre California unicornes
donc du coup dans ces deux équipes
américaines avec de très très très haut
niveau aujourd'hui Samy
je sais pas si tu as la composition
entre les yeux sinon je peux te la
donner moi je ne l'ai pas donc je
tenterai vas-y et non les stars qui vont
s'affronter ouais alors du coup on va
avoir attends je retrouve juste le bon
truc là donc on a dans l'équipe 1 donc
l'équipe des Gotham Knights on a
première table
icaruna camera que vous voyez déjà la
caméra en haut
qui d'ailleurs
c'est la chemise avec les ananas ou pas
je crois que c'est des fleurs je sais
pas faut résumer mais en tout cas
derrière on voit au mur il y en a un qui
accroché
donc Nakamura tête de série numéro 1
avec fedoce numéro 2
vostikov numéro 3 donc c'est un jeune
ouzbek de 16 17 ans qui a fait dormir
ou pas
je sais plus
j'ai pas le souvenir
ça me dit rien mais en tout cas c'est un
jeune qui a gagné la médaille d'or aux
Olympiques
et puis on a du coup comme féminine nure
MANOVA donc je ne connais pas du tout à
la 2164 je ne connais pas du tout
et du coup en face et ben c'est ça me
change numéro 1 donc contre les Caro on
aura aussi rérubson numéro 2 donc 2700
aussi tables 2 c'est très fort
et au troisième table on aura du coup
Christopher you donc un jeune aussi qui
a 16 ans qui a quasiment 2600 hello
très dangereux aussi et on a aussi coûte
4e table la féminine c'est Zoé Tang que
je ne connais pas du tout non plus qui a
2183 donc un match qui est très
équilibré on voit que les moyennes et
l'eau elles sont à 2547 contre 2543 donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment hyper
hyper close mais c'est vrai que Naka
quand même
est capable de faire un petit cadre sur
80 ils sont en coiffe voilà je crois que
oui
SALUT Fatou salut à tous bonsoir tout le
monde salut Fatou salut
slip box est-ce que tu es pas trop déçu
d'ailleurs qui est pas goûté c'est tout
ce soir
qui participait à un gros tournoi il a
battu il a gagné hier roi du coup
aujourd'hui il a mieux à faire que ça
effectivement donc oui je suis déjà
falloir comme tu le sais mais je suis
aussi content de le voir si bien marché
dans son tournoi il est leader ex aequo
avec avec Aronian
et le Sud tous les jours c'est parti ça
je le non
casse tout vous en parle dans le chat
aussi c'est pas clair parce que on
rappelle la cadence c'est du c'est du
rapide hein c'est 10 + 2 c'est ça 10 + 2
c'est bien ça ok c'est pas du 3 + 0
là où n'a qu'à y règne un petit peu en
mètre sur internet en rapide il est
quand même davantage prenable d'ailleurs
on a vu la semaine dernière c'était la
sensation il est perdu la première ronde
contre
la joueuse de 1200 et quelques équipes
Albert donc c'était la sensation c'est
ça et que voilà c'est pas à 4 sur 4
d'accord assurer en tout cas
je te mets des
caméras pour pour cette ronde
sont deux équipes qui ont gagné toutes
les deux leur premier match donc celles
qui s'imposera ce soir pendant une
grosse option pour la qualification
c'est ça parce que le système c'est ça
il faut trois victoires je crois sur les
5 premiers matchs en gros pour accéder à
la phase de playoff
donc avec deux sur deux l'équipe se met
très très bien
j'ai pas vu qui a gagné c'est quoi le
nom de l'équipe qui vient de gagner le
premier match on a pas stream
j'ai pas suivi pour te dire j'étais très
occupé
quels sont les équipes à deux sur deux
je crois qu'il y a les images
parce que tu regardes mon écran en fait
c'est assez simple
c'est ça que je savais pas faire hier
voilà les bulles d'eau qui ont gagné 9 7
ok ils avaient perdu je crois la
première journée donc
ils reviennent à une Victoria beaucoup
notamment
peut-être l'équipe qui va perdre ce
match de ce soir d'ailleurs on aimerait
bien dans la compète un petit match
entre discrim et
Gotham Knights
Kevin et Gotham qui joue exceptionnel
mais je pense pas que ce soit très bien
de toute façon ils ont des coéquipiers
très très fort et qui préfèrent laisser
la place a priori
ok donc j'ai toujours pas les il y a
deux joueurs dans la dans l'équipe de
déco thème qui ne veulent pas venir
s'asseoir du coup je ne sais pas
tarder de toute façon il y en a un qui a
une chambre rose alors j'ai envie de me
dire que c'est la fille minime je me
trompe peut-être
c'est tout rose
non je sais pas du tout mais mais je
peux te je peux te dire si tu veux c'est
Zoé Tang je vais Google et tout de suite
vu qu'elles ont toutes les deux entre
2150 et 2200 je crois tu le disais un
peu l'inconnu donc si on a une qui
arrive à performer ça peut vraiment
faire la différence pour son équipe
pourtant à la 2184 sur internet mais bon
sur la file c'est 2063 et elle a 15 ans
donc OK et son adversaire
qui est-ce c'est hallua nurmanova que je
ne connais pas du tout non plus je vais
la Google home
pour le point classement je regarde un
bouton
de un an de plus donc 16 ans et là de
2231 en feed par contre alors du coup
les élo je sais pas du coup
pourquoi il y a marqué 2164 et 2183
alors que c'est pas du tout ces Enola
ils ont pris le hello peut-être ça
change chaque mois donc au moment ils
l'ont pris c'était peut-être deux mois
dans le début de la compétition un truc
comme ça ils ont pu gagner des points
depuis
elle elle a gagné 50 points depuis pas
assez largement possible à son âge
60 points alors que l'autre ouais c'est
ça Thomas c'est les lots de novembre
donc
ah oui il y a même qui a fait plus de 60
l'autre fait - 100 quoi
le lien c'est la page event de la
project
pour tous les tournois que vous suivez
n'hésitez pas c'est là où vous pouvez
voir toutes les parties vous avez des
infos sur les horaires les rondes et
dans le résultat il y a le petit point
classiquement virtuel et donc on voit
qu'il y a trois équipes qui ont gagné
leurs deux premiers matchs donc on a
comme je disais tout à l'heure les yogi
les petits produits indiens on a des
turgate ice Girls qui ont battublit hier
stuff et aussi les les sorciers les
Wizards qui ont quatre points l'équipe
avec la plus forte
donc Sami je vais t'annoncer que la
chambre rose était bien le garçon et
voilà mais
j'ai failli primoof tu sais je suis dit
bon c'est pas tu sais on sait jamais
c'est les goûts les couleurs de chacun
et du coup par contre lui avec sa
chambre rose et ben il est parti il est
plus sur le mythe donc je ne peux
toujours pas le prendre sa caméra mais
sinon tout va bien je suis prêt donc on
va voir comme première partie un
Nakamura contre Tang c'est déjà où là
vous le voyez du coup à la
à la à la caméra les parties qui sont
pas encore lancées donc on va attendre
un petit peu je pense que ça va pas
tarder à arriver on n'a pas d'heure
en vacances quoi
ouais non mais il est à l'aise je pense
qu'il est content de faire cette
événement
tu vois et donc on va voir si la
première partie
va lui poser un petit déconvenu comme
comme la semaine dernière contre
Joséphine Hyman
vous avez une étude favorite ou pas j'ai
vu quelques messages notamment sur les
licornes en début de string
c'est un peu comme avec Messi Ronaldo
quoi j'ai envie de dire
du coup c'est l'équivalent j'imagine de
au fur et à mesure on va avoir vraiment
des affiches a priori de plus en plus
excitantes sur le papier
je sais pas il y a pas mal mais bon ça
devrait pas tarder en fait donc en fait
sur les caméras de l'équipe de Nakamura
il manque un joueur il manque audikov OK
et du coup tu as peut-être pour ça qu'il
y a du retard je sais pas
mais en plus c'est vrai que sur Internet
bah il joue tout et il adore ses
cadences là
et au final ben écoute c'est une équipe
qui est extrêmement dangereuse enfin les
deux équipes sont plus dangereuses mais
j'ai l'impression que l'équipe des
California unicornes tu sais c'est plus
tu vois je vois champion de numéro 1 bon
est très fort champion je le respecte
énormément mais c'est pas un cas tu vois
par exemple
il peut se faire il peut se raccrocher
par un 2005
un peu moins bon ça peut aussi arriver
bien sûr mais c'est différent tu vois
c'est un profil plus solide quoi plus
fiable
et pareil en Robson il est plus solide
j'ai l'impression il se met souvent mal
au temps j'ai vu le match à la dernière
fois le match Robson c'était contre les
contrôler les Croates et Robson il était
mal autant souvent en fait après
note tout le temps c'est compliqué alors
que du coup fait d'essayev c'est pas le
genre à être mal au temps
[Musique]
OK
ils ont une équipe ils ont que des
grands-mères sur la liste il y a une
liste on peut se remettre jusqu'à 10
joueurs et il y a que des grands maîtres
donc même leur fille c'est que des
grands maîtres alors si vous voulez je
peux vous montrer un petit peu les
forces en présence ici vous avez à
l'écran
vous avez du coup Nakamura fedoc
vos kids qui n'est pas encore là et du
coup nur MANOVA et du coup à l'envers
vous avez chanclan Robson
et en fait ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que en élo c'est even quand tu
voyais Nakamura sans clan si il y a 50
points d'écart fait d'essayer et Robson
il y a 15 points d'écart et vos kids et
you bah c'est pareil il y a cinq points
d'écart et les filles pareil et du coup
en fait je trouve que c'est c'est hyper
intéressant c'est un match qui vraiment
et hyper hyper serré alors que
généralement soit dans une équipe on a
une fille à 2005-2006 et
plus condensé tu vois on apprend plus de
plus de gens à 2006 et moins de grandes
stars mais mais des joueurs plus forts
sur le papier alors que là souvent bah
tu as plusieurs jours à 2007-2008 mais
du coup tu as une fille à 2100 donc du
coup du coup intéressant je pense que
homogène sont peut-être les plus on a vu
hier encore une fois contre Blitz on a
vu les les Chinois qui étaient hyper
homogènes ils avaient pas vraiment de
faiblesse c'est ça alors que Ben nous
bon on avait quand même une fille assez
forte et très magique qui est quand même
aussi non mais bon ça va quand même que
ils ont quasiment que des grands maîtres
donc ça c'est il y a l'expérience aussi
et
tu vois dans un match par exemple hier
j'ai commandé encore une fois le match
[Musique]
hier j'ai commenté le match
oui
c'était les Saint-Louis Bishop contre
l'équipe des Indiens là à eagasi et en
fait Henri
IV 2005 et un jeune grand maître indien
à 2500 mital et en fait
une seconde tu peux continuer de
raconter n'hésite pas à mettre les chic
et peut-être en même temps mais du coup
en fait les les
américains ils avaient un joueur enfin
une chose à 2300 derniers qui a fait
zéro et en fait ben c'est c'est hyper
dur Quentin joueur qui fait zéro donc ça
a commencé hop là vous avez la partie en
direct
et c'est marrant parce que moi il manque
toujours un joueur en fait dans le dans
le truc il manque une caméra
de caméra c'est tout
mais il n'est pas là
donc c'est quoi
5 jours 5 ça existe d'ailleurs tu l'as
déjà joué
exactement la même chose que lui donc je
vais certainement pas critiquer
ok alors H5 le coup en fait par rapport
à la structure je vous explique un petit
peu dans la structure et Ben se fout de
case noire il est hyper mauvais parce
que tous les pions sont gaz noir et même
si je suis en train quinté et du coup en
fait l'idée de faire H5 c'est de pouvoir
faire foi H6 et échanger cette mauvaise
pièce F4 qui permet d'ouvrir la position
donc là je sais pas du tout c'est bien
ou pas mais bon pourquoi pas intéressant
elle joue elle veut prendre sa chance
elle a raison c'est comme ça qu'elle
pourra le mettre en difficulté donc elle
attaque c'est c'est intéressant comme
position ici fougères mais j'ai quand
même peur que quelqu'un de 5 pose
problème sur le long terme ici
est-ce qu'Avignon HC il fait un peu de
peine pour l'instant on va voir
intéressant
de sauter pourquoi pas au G4 le but le
rêve stratégique des Noirs c'est de
réussir à échanger un fond un cavalier
donc les deux cavaliers adverses il se
retrouverait un cavalier en 5 contre le
foot casse blanche des plans à bloquer
là sa structure mais bon on en est pas
là mais
dans les faits c'est quand même
comme ça que ça pourrait tourner
comme ça
et déjà déjà j'aime bien les droits
de visu parce que tu veux qu'on fasse un
petit tour rapidement
je vais vous changer les caméras sont
déjà prêtes
sur le tableau 3 il va manquer un joueur
donc ça c'est une ligne fait voir la
sylliane
américaine oui
[Musique]
j'essaie de reconnaître en fait à sa
tête
et en fait il faut à chaque fois que je
change toutes les lignes enfin toutes
les
positions et qu'on revient sur un cadre
ce sont pas obligé de tout rechanger à
chaque fois
ok donc là c'est la clé avec les Blancs
c'est c'est you qui a 16 ans et contre
fedos seiev 2700 Hello
de Prague qui avait gagné ici avec les
blancs en position comme ça c'était le
tournoi il y a pas si longtemps que ça
et d'ailleurs j'ai vu marrant c'était
Libye qu'il a rejoint aussi pareil
avec les Blancs contre un 200400 en
Bundesliga et les mecs étaient pas
pareil encore mieux que que Prague
c'était la folie il a quand même réussi
à gagner mais c'était un ou deux un truc
de ouf
mais Caval est bien c'était pas la ligne
que je l'avais vu je crois que c'était
puis on prend la ligne un truc comme ça
et c'est hyper compliqué parce qu'il y a
tout en fait
des deux côtés
mais on a l'impression que les blancs
peuvent réclamer les cases blanches
noires avec le foot 15 mois donc du coup
c'est une partie en tout cas
intéressante il y a des cases tu vois il
y a cavalier là qui peut venir tu vois
j'ai qu'un des pinses qui sont à ma
portée avec les Blancs donc c'est
intéressant tu vois comment ça se passe
mais déjà
ok bah vas-y continue peut-être la
troisième partie alors vous qui d'oeuf
donc ça c'est bon la fameuse
[Musique]
sa réussite ça on connaît toutes les
pour verrouiller sauf peut-être que la
stratégie se dit avec les Blancs et joue
contre Robson qui est plus fort si je
vous fais des nuls avec les Blancs et
que nos meilleurs joueurs gagnent
moi je suis pas sûr ils sont tous jeunes
ils vont tous je pense qu'ils veulent
tout seul
oui non c'est bon après là il a quand
même sacré de pions
et donc après ça je connais pas du tout
je connais rien sur ça j'imagine qu'il
va être le fou article comme ça je me
suis fait un peu
je crois que c'était critique justement
de prendre ce pion
ouais parce que sinon
est-ce que ça va nous avancer parce que
même sur ton A3 genre tomber un four à 3
je vais tomber trois tours et je vais
peut-être lancer une attaque rapidement
là-haut
dangereux effectivement
sur des coups même de manière générale
alors troisième partie du coup ça va
être vos kids non c'est ça va être du
coup
cinq clans qui jouent ici
donc là j'ai pas la caméra je suis
désolé alors tant que je crois que non
c'est
contre nurma vachage je pense que je
peux vous la mettre la caméra que vous
voyez un petit peu qui est qui
joueuse Ouzbeks c'est ça dans kazak
et le problème en fait c'est que du coup
si je fais ça je dois remettre une
caméra mais qui va non je vais pas vous
la mettre la caméra je suis désolé je
n'ai pas envie
de te retrouver après parce qu'en fait
si tu veux
tout est réglé parce qu'il manque un
joueur dans le mythe si je règle après
mais du coup je vous la mettre dès que
le joint arrive et mon groupe idoff à
l'appel
qui a surgit en A5 souvent une bonne
nouvelle pour les blancs dans ce genre
de position moi j'aime bien les blancs
ici
le pion voici c'est faible
le centre blanc est quand même assez
solide
ouais peut-être un petit plus blanc que
la couverture c'est bien très bien passé
pour la joueuse de l'équipe des licornes
de l'équipe de Gotham c'est ça
peut-être son clan avoir des qu'au début
mais après encore beaucoup de choses à
faire il y a aussi l'expérience qui qui
va parler mais c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup les blancs
qui va avancer ça peut être très
dangereux pour les deux mais bon on
agent encore que 15 coups il y a encore
pas mal de choses à faire ça reste assez
standard mais c'est quand même bien
passé pour le blanc et oui le taux
effectivement on a pas vu ta question
tout à l'heure c'est un joint de se
présente pas est-ce qu'il y a un forfait
écoute
figure ne s'est jamais produit ça paraît
improbable
mais
en plus en sachant qu'on inscrit à
plusieurs joueurs sur la liste peut-être
qu'il aura remplaçant dernière minute
mais
on n'a pas la réponse mais je suppose
que ça doit être forfait mais je pense
s'il est pas là tu as perdu quoi je
pense que c'est produire quand même non
non les joueurs ils sont après si
vraiment il y a un problème technique à
Internet que si que ça bon j'ai envie de
dire c'est quand même ta faute mais bon
comme ça important tu prévois quoi tu
fais pas ça au dernier moment
je me souviens un match de speechester
ou bah c'était pas contre un Maxime
d'ailleurs
ouais je crois que c'est peut-être le
Maxime
chez lui du coup il avait dû aller jouer
à la médiathèque
il était hyper perturbé pendant le match
il est pas dans son assiette du tout
quoi
mais il avait prévu parce que ouais je
monte il est pas eu des
grosses intempéries à cette époque donc
toute la zone était coupée au niveau
Internet
la souris tout quoi
en tout cas s'il était la s'il était à
la médiathèque ça veut dire qu'il était
pas avachi sur son sa chaise comme
d'habitude
il a fait exactement ce que tu avais dit
Samy avec ce petit cavalier en 5 et il
va jamais bien sûr manger là sauf si il
y a du matériel à manger etc mais le but
ça va te changer lui contre lui pour
mettre un autre cavalier ici
et donc là du coup il commence à
attaquer maintenant sur l'autre flanc
regarde la porte
mais attention parce que on se rappelle
la semaine c'était relâché il était déjà
complètement gagnant entre Joséphine et
neymad quand il avait perdu donc là je
vois mal ce qui pourrait lui arriver
mais on va voir on va voir et c'est
cavalier monstrueux qui domine
complètement la position qui tient la
seule faiblesse des Noirs le pion F7
peut-être
ces cases pour sur la prise prise mettre
un autre cavalier en C5
[Musique]
jours qui manquent à la pelle il y a
quelques heures il y a dixing
donc c'est un peu normal qu'il soit pas
là
il manque encore
on a les raisins qui qui absorbe
ça a été annoncé
un petit peu la mode pour le chrome
geste tour comme une bonne nouvelle pour
les supporters
bienvenue à toi
C4 qui risque d'arriver derrière
c'est pour le coup c'est vraiment un
plomb on peut le dire
la position il sert à rien il est là et
là en plus elle a un tour qui peut venir
aussi derrière en C7 un moment donné la
colonne c'est qui va être prise
et
franchement ça aurait été ça aurait été
marrant tu vois vu en fait tu vois quand
on voit la quand on quand vous voyez les
caméras à la sur le stream et ben on
voit comme la différence tu vois on a
une enfant qui joue contre Nakamura ça
aurait été vraiment marrant de l'avoir à
la coller à Dakar j'en ai trop aimé tu
vois c'est son cocktail là mon avis ils
sont smoothie ça va pas être très pousse
c'est clair non parce que tu vois bon
Joséphine
ce qu'elle a fait et franchement
mais bon elle elle a plus 15 ans
maintenant tu vois et du coup en fait
j'aurais bien aimé
ou alors gars pour l'ego de Naka c'est
le fait
imagine les réseaux sociaux voilà c'est
mal à regarder
[Musique]
de faire chercher le chat ça allait trop
vite on a pas eu le temps qui finit 33
partie c'était abusé alors juste pour
vous montrer la fin de la partie quand
même que c'est assez joli il a doublé là
pour menacer le petit tour prend à deux
et surtout reprend mais à tout reprendre
et surprendre Damas 5 avec Mat au
prochain coup sur MA3
la stratégie d'abord et comme souvent
vous faites quand toutes nos pièces sont
bien placées quand on domine
positionnellement
au service de la stratégie et il a
conclu par cette petite combinaison
il ouvre le score pour les chevaliers
donc là vous avez essayé
on a dit
à la partie je te l'informatique de bois
je suis gentil mais il y a quand tu
direct donc il faut qu'on
rap vite je te la femme accélérer mais
je sais pas si il demandait la partie de
Naka d'ailleurs bon celle de Yo
j'imagine peut-être le donner un cas je
pense qu'il faut des Naka le plus peur
de bois mais moi comme ça je j'arrête
c'est le cas
donc nakave et les Noirs avant celle-là
contre la jeune
contre la jeune tanzoé
je continue
le direct de cheescom tu sais
que tu as automatique voilà
comme on le disait il a joué juste sur
la super idée de du cavalier E5 par
rapport au foot blanc très solide
pour pousser à l'aide
en fait on a l'impression qu'on tourne
en rond qu'on n'arrive pas à améliorer
notre position
ça va très vite et ça y est c'était déjà
décisif en fait
là
en B7 pour se passer la tour et là boum
tour à deux
et le Mad avec Damas 5 et 3 d'apprendre
la France allez revenons maintenant du
coup sur
sur la partie de you contre philosophe
salut les équipes
un petit peu froid au milieu des
courants
[Musique]
de plus pour le noir juste même si c'est
anecdotique ici mais genre il y a même
pas davantage matériel pour les blancs
ils ont un bon cavalier le
4e
B2 qui peut arriver aussi
là c'est une hérité du roi est trop
importante ici
c'est très dur
petit poussin de bois c'est sévère après
la joueuse tanga elle a 2100 2160
dans l'ouverture ensuite il déroule
c'est tellement facile trop de
différence de niveau plus certainement
c'est son premier match elle joue contre
NACA elle doit avoir pas mal de pression
de stress pas forcément facile pour elle
de lâcher ses coups
on espère que ça se passera mieux les
parties suivantes d'accord ça marche
gloire
[Musique]
et ça serait l'occasion là pour les
stouf on a eu un résultat tu vas aller
voir peut-être ça me change Land le
premier équipier des licornes a fait le
taf aussi il a égalisé pour son équipe
il joue contre qui pardon
contre
justement en train de mettre sa caméra
donc ça va être parfait ah non c'est pas
ça
il y avait une position prometteuse à la
sortie de l'ouverture mais
le résultat c'est assez finalement mal
passé on va voir comment certainement
de problèmes du sale position
toujours dans la dernière partie entre
rire et Robson et vous qui doivent
c'est une boisson le temps
Google
pas que OK
salut du Copat
bonjour au chat
une question que je me posais aussi du
coup
un truc en poudre un truc en poudre
froid ça doit pas être très bon ça non
ça m'inspire pas des bases confiance
mais bon c'était celle-là mais en fait
du coup j'ai changé c'est du coup les
caméras sont apparus et je voulais donc
costarité ici à cavalle à 5 et Europe
tour à deux c'est un peu dommage ça
c'est un peu
la position blanche c'est quand même
ouais
je vois pas trop comment ça a pu le
tourner si vite pour elle
position quand même
je l'ai mis ma défenseur
ok bon grosse gaffe tu reviens du coup
sur vos kids ou sur
position
mais quand même le roi blanc est
toujours à poil au milieu de l'Égypte il
est assez
petites faire un petit peu attention
mais normalement
tout est défendu tout est défendu on
peut imaginer un petit tour
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que la
table noire peut faire des échecs à tout
moment si la Torse mon action G4 en F4
H4
les deux pièces lourdes s'activent en
même temps et ça risque de mater aussi
dans l'air
la presse trop de choix ici en fait de
cf
ouais un truc quand même surtout G8
est-ce que je peux pas faire échec OK et
chaque d'un point qui est 6 enfin
attention quand même
variante
j'ai des trucs qui ont là
j'ai plein d'échecs qui peuvent être un
peu déplaisants avec le fou qui peut
rentrer en jeu d'avoir F4 tu vois c'est
pas simple
mais un bon tu manges tous les pions
quand même avec les noirs
c'est fini il est peut-être pas décape
ta mère chaque roi là faut prendre des
quatre
vida c'est très joli et du coup la
dernière partie vous l'avez en direct
vous avez enfin bon les genres les noms
des joueurs n'est pas bon je vais vous
le changer de suite mais vous avez avec
les Noirs vous avez en
Haute-Saône qui joue contre du coup
vokidoff
tu disais qu'il avait 16 ans
je ne sais pas quel âge il a mais ouais
je crois que c'est après ça ouais
la thématique moi j'ai vu quel âge il
avait maintenant
je dirais rien enfin
tout veuille le faire
pour son équipe et a priori
la de plus en plus on se trouve donc
ça a l'air d'être
plus qu'une question de technique
en plus il a le couple dame cavalier on
voit que l'option c'est 6 il s'en fout
ici ce qui compte il a son pion à passer
éloigné son roi il va trouver un abri et
le fouet les noirs
[Musique]
moi je vote pas parce que j'ai vu la
réponse
moi je vote pas j'ai vu la réponse
pour pas nous aider
dans le noir avec sa petite chambre rose
c'était lui la chambre rose violette
mais c'est
non mais j'avais cette celle-là et en
plus une autre hyper bien rangé et tout
je dis bon
ça pourrait être le fils de la moitié du
chat
les amis sont partagés en tout cas 1 2 3
4 ça fait 0 1 2 3 4 ça fait un petit
escalier la quinte
voilà ça va changer les pièces et même
si tu avais deux on va tout échanger et
se retrouver avec deux pions passés donc
Robson qui marque ce point du coup ça
fait 2 2 dans ce premier dans cette
première enfin ce premier set du coup
donc on avait dit un depuis le début on
avait dit que c'est un match qui allait
être hyper serré et pour l'instant bah
du coup il y a pas eu vraiment de
surprise en terme d'élo tous les favoris
ont gagné exactement
ça a l'air d'être
une clinique avec les noirs
[Musique]
du coup on aura peur la ronde 2 on va
voir Nakamura qui aura cette fois-ci les
blancs
[Musique]
cette fois-ci
hop
contre Christie you contre Christopher
you
ici avec les noirs pour
la deuxième partie du pourquoi j'ai un
ça l'équipe
des goternens sont largement favoris sur
ces deux échiquiers
mais à l'inverse ça me change qui aura
les blancs contre vous qui Daf et Robson
qui aura les blancs contre l'urbanova
donc là aussi le score vraiment logique
ce serait un nouveau de touffe puisque
les joueurs les mieux placés ont les
blancs en plus si tout est correct
on pourrait bien se diriger vers un
nouveau de deux mais bon quand même
avoir plein de surprises est-ce qu'on a
la réponse touf de l'âge le chat a voté
majoritairement pour les 17 ans est-ce
que il a eu raison non
pas eu raison il me dit pas qu'il a 15
ans
[Musique]
alors je vais vous répondre de suite la
première ronde de partout les deux
équipes pour l'instant dos à dos
[Musique]
contre
alors attends
je vais devoir regarder moi-même là
puisque je sens que tout est beaucoup
trop longtemps
alors
je vais vous donner la réponse comment
je fais la réponse à tout il a l'âge que
j'aurais pu dire du coup tu nous as
[Musique]
je sais pas comment faire tous les
disparu chez moi
quoi donner la réponse tu sais
officiellement tu veux dire il y a rien
à gagner mais
[Musique]
c'est que là il a disparu et quand je
fais Paul encore une fois
[Musique]
j'ai pas le talent
et bravo à vous
contre
et voilà donc c'est moi tout est prêt
et du coup on va avoir un petit Nakamura
qui va jouer contre Zoé Tang non pardon
contre je crois que elle a plus envie
elle serait pas très contente un jeune
aka à chaque ronde non non ouais c'est
pas très drôle c'est marrant de le jouer
mais après quand on en joue trop on
finit par en avoir un peu marre je sais
de quoi reptinaca
[Musique]
donc du coup voilà deux deux lors de ce
premier set et la ronde de enfin le
deuxième set qui devrait être qui
devrait commencer dans un dans un
instant
on n'a pas encore les appareils mais on
attend je vois pas ce qu'il mange
il parle beaucoup en tout cas
pour lui sur sa chaîne non non
j'avais déjà vu qu'on en avait commenté
le premier match de nacar et c'est lui
qui
faille streamer donc il y a des
événements tu as pas le droit mais bon
après là c'est quand même hyper
surveillé le
ce match ce tournoi des caméras partout
stream tu mets tu es obligé de mettre
ton chat en émotes only
donc
de messages à la seconde sur le chat de
Naka
[Rires]
presque c'est un peu c'est un peu ouf
voilà
donc là du coup j'ai aussi mis le chat
en émoticônes
c'est la seule qui peut faire c'est pour
c'était pour montrer
[Musique]
du coup alors ronde de toujours pas là
je crois mais ça va arriver on attend
donc là les appareils
répéter Naka blanc contre Christopher
you fedocef plan contre Tang et de
l'autre côté c'est chanclan blanc contre
Rocky doof et Robson blanc contre Norman
Nova
donc voilà avoir en tout cas ça va
commencer dans un instant
mais je pense que la plus intéressante
ça va être la dernière ronde en vrai
parce que là ça va être pile ou face
l'impression
mais plus la roue mais plus la rendre 4
ou la lettre de fille pourront vraiment
exprimer quoi
parce que là les filles elles sont
fortes mais bon
2100-2200 contre le genre à 2700
on a un fan de ce tour dans le chat oui
non mais j'ai l'habitude avec avec
Oliver ça me fait des mois tu me fais ça
même sur youtube il me fait pareil
t'inquiète
mais salut à toi
je suis le vrai sache-le
mais pas de souci et un petit poussin de
bois parfois
des questions pendant ces petites pauses
entre chaque ronde
pour aller notamment visiter la chaîne
de stouffe
d'ailleurs j'ai prévu de reprendre le
stream du coup demain après-midi
j'étais absent pendant un long moment
mais du coup ben ça va je vais reprendre
bientôt demain
demain demain Pikachu tout comment que
tu streamas en costume de Pikachu ou pas
déjà il y a une vidéo qui va venir qui
va arriver sur Youtube
très bientôt j'espère
j'attends que qu'on me fasse les les
réglages et tout mais j'ai fait un
tournoi vous avez carnaval là où je suis
au Canaries et en fait du coup il y
avait un tournoi et une des conditions
pour participer au tournoi c'était
d'être déguisé donc j'avais acheté un
déguisement Pikachu immense tellement
immense pur entrer dedans c'était l'idée
et du coup j'ai croisé il y avait un
gamin qui avait 9 ans ou 10 ans et qui
était aussi déguisé en Pikachu je me
suis sentie un petit peu
un petit peu grand pour ça mais écoute
c'était cool
c'est ça et du coup les parents ils ont
vu bon c'était marrant et du coup je
suis l'avoir gamin je lui ai dit donc je
lui ai parlé un peu etc et j'ai pris des
photos avec gamins
Pikachu et Pikachu quoi les parents ils
étaient trop content ils ont pris un
milliard de photos aussi et à la fin
j'ai proposé un petit Blitz à l'enfant
donc on a fait plutôt un Bullet parce
qu'on n'avait pas le temps donc je l'ai
fait un pullet avec un gamin de 9 ans je
sais pas j'ai honte de rien mais mais
bon la route elle a commencé et du coup
j'aimerais mettre cette vidéo sur
Youtube je vais pouvoir laisser en fait
c'est marrant parce que c'est Pikachu
compliqué
en IRL donc c'est marrant après la
partie aucun intérêt mais sinon c'est
c'est assez marrant donc voilà j'ai pris
des photos aussi cette fille le temps là
je n'ai pas gagné j'ai fait un mauvais
tournoi c'était long tu avais 45 minutes
par an un truc comme ça
la cadence est de 3 minutes plus quelque
chose en fait l'incrément et ben tirer
la partie et du coup comment tu as très
sérieux donc non mais j'ai un droit qui
était pas homologué ni rien tu vois mais
en fait
tu lances le dé pour faire pour faire
ton encrement avant la partie et
en plus six toutes les parties ben moi
j'ai jamais eu aussi j'ai eu un une ou
deux fois mais après j'ai toujours eu
quatre ou cinq
et par contre j'ai eu sur quatre parties
mes adversaires qui avaient une seconde
à chaque fois
étonnant et du coup à un moment donné je
jouais un gars à 2200 et j'avais quatre
contre deux ou 52 j'avais je crois en
termes de ouais je crois que j'avais 5
condenses en terme d'ingrément
et à un moment donné je joue un coup et
je me rends compte qu'il me reste deux
jours dans la pendule en fait j'ai mal
réglé et lui il joue avec 3 + 2 et - 3 +
et alors que j'avais 5 secondes parcours
à chaque fois et du coup à la fin de la
partie il manquait du temps tu vois je
dis merde du coup
on m'a remis l’incrément mais bon
j'avais 6 secondes contre une minute
c'est parti un petit moment oui tout à
l'heure
pourtant elle est où je la vois pas
moi j'ai trouvé mais à moins
5 ok
ok ça a commencé donc la carte qui joue
pas très théorique j'ai l'impression
c'est quoi cette ouverture
c'est la partie je l'ai gagné mais
j'avais c'était marrant j'avais deux
dames
contre une dame et deux pièces et demi
je crois
donc j'ai pu remonter vite mais c'était
pas facile
et pas fan de l'ouverture de Dakar non
plus je trouve que les noirs sont bien
il y a le centre
qui joue une sorte de sicilienne
donc c'est une Sicilienne un petit peu
chelou encore une fois et Cavaillon
l'eau
je pense qu'il n'a pas de table
OK
faut trois cavaliers de 7 Dame des deux
qui serait vraiment du pain béni pour
les blancs
C4 et pour C5
plus tard mais même même d'un B4 est
passé des villes on aime bien en fait
provoquer des faiblesses et MBK c'est
pas comment on défense plus en fait
parce que pour là je vais vous prendre à
et si tu joues B6 je viens là bon non
j'ai quand même bien faut pas oublier
mais dans l'idée peut-être ça et ça
c'est pas débile
pourquoi pas
un petit rat donc là on va sûrement un
petit appui C4 je pense quand même il y
a des choses
tu crois que C4 et après voir un peu si
joue B4 il joue tour C1 ou un truc comme
ça mais c'est clair que ça le jeu des
blancs est allé et clairement à l'eldame
que les Noirs dorment plutôt jeu pour F5
je pense alors je sais pas encore
comment faire
ça peut être aussi dynamique mais bon
j'attends toujours
comme ça
je jouais des choses comme ça
que je trouve assez voilà exactement
du mal à trouver du contre-jourd’hui F5
souvent on se fait pas grand chose et
c'est long faut déjà bouger le cavalier
je pense que je vois bien une victoire
assez tranquille de fait d'Océane dans
cette partie façon encore une fois c'est
déséquilibré les filles de ces équipes
là elles vont avoir des matchs
difficiles contre les leaders il y a
quand même beaucoup enfin une grosse
différence au niveau entre les joueurs
[Musique]
allez on va avoir peut-être
les caméras en même temps je vous ai pas
mis tout à l'heure je suis un clan vos
kiders donc les noms sont là mais vous
changerez les noms après là on fait
juste un petit tour 2006 hein
il a largement
mais bien sûr et aussi
[Musique]
on a qu'à moi qui joue contre Yuki aussi
enfin qui est aussi de
160000 je perds des États-Unis en partie
Landes cette année donc quand même très
dangereux
je crois qu'il me semble qu'il avait
fait justement cette performance
décevante avec beaucoup de nuls mais je
peux me tromper peut-être
il joue que les
événements tu vois
ça mais de l'autre côté
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici ça
m'étonnerait qu'à 5 soit quand même un
bon coup
après bon bah tu peux manger là et
manger là et manger là et après mettre
un cavalier vert
plus pour les Noirs mais bon les blancs
quand même le centre le cavalier en
bedro il est à la fois beau mais il fait
pas non plus toujours grand-chose
pour difficile d'évaluer vraiment cette
pièce c'est ça que ça peut être un coup
il dit que sur C5 des 5 peut-être du
cavalier de 4
donc regardez l'idée en fait
je joue le coup mais c'est peut-être pas
bon
en fait s'il mange puis on prend et ben
j'ai dû à tour qui va venir ici car ça
c'est écrasant pour les noirs et du coup
c'était peut-être le coup parce que du
coup ben non mais la chose elle n'a pas
bougé
alors kf5
après la prise ben tu vois je le gagne
la case des cinq aussi des fois que les
Noirs si je peux arriver à mettre une
pièce ça peut être pas mal donc il faut
voir c'est compliqué parce que là il y a
des échecs de partout il y a des trucs
c'est clairement un truc qu'il faut tu
vois un caballer le 5 je pensais pas à
cavale
pas le temps de faire tout ce que je
veux
mais encore une fois c'est ça qui est
toujours d'actualité je pense avec la
même idée tout à l'heure aussi
ok alors ça j'aime pas parce qu'il y
aura ça
ok il va ouvrir
tous ses pions ouais bon bah écoute il y
a quand même du jeu il y a quand même
derrière une position compliquée il y a
six qui a été joué sur pions
juste pour dire bah écoute j'ai trois
pions pour la pièce et je vais ensuite
essayer de mettre en marche un moment
donné j'arrive à jouer d4c5 ça va être
très très fort c'est un très intéressant
comme je vois pratique et tu vois encore
une fois le joueur il a il a 2006 il est
jeune et il en veut
en pratique ça fait peur quoi
[Musique]
de confirmer
tout de suite peut-être parce qu'il y a
quand même un vis-à-vis et ça en prise
qui n'est pas une menace parce qu'il y a
un il y aura sûrement une découverte là
dessus mais peut-être un coup de dames
mais je pensais comme dameuse 7 pour
attaquer là et menacer des quatre mais
je suis pas sûr avec toi
il faut la bouger quelque part je pense
parce que là du coup des cadres à moins
que je vous déclare d'ailleurs j'arrive
à laisser 5 mais bon ça fait tu vois
c'est il y a quand même des vis-à-vis
aussi par là
des quatre ok donc là je suis quand même
défendu hein
justement où les favoris sont fait
respecter la première ronde
même si jamais il arrivait imaginons
juste pour voir
fousser un détroit imagine bien la dame
comment elle pourra pas bouger tu vois
les pièces les pièces les pièces
blanches qui me vont plus jamais de la
partie donc juste en terme de
positionnel j'ai une pièce de moins j'ai
quand même trois temps pour la pièce
donc matériellement je suis pas derrière
mais regarde un petit peu la position
des questions qui peuvent pas bouger
quoi j'ai pas de casse c'est c'est une
horreur donc là on peut juste jouer
d'échec normalement sachant que le fou
la dame ne feront plus jamais a priori
même le Caval il y a pas de case c'est
très très dur extrêmement dur ici pour
les pour les blancs j'aime beaucoup ce
que nous fait du coup vous kids en cette
partie
non pardon pourquoi j'ai les deux filles
ensemble j'ai fait une erreur
je sors en bas
la joueuse
opson qui a les blancs donc clairement
qui parle largement favori il a
500 points et l'eau de plus
mais on a une position intéressante
une espèce de standienne finalement où
la position pour l'instant très fermée
moi je trouve que pour l'instant on y
MANOVA elle se bat quand même bien
contre son clan de moins la gaffe et une
tactique mais elle avait une position
très équilibrée jusque là
pour l'instant elle a l'air quand même
plus plus dangereuse peut-être que temps
mais avoir au fur et à mesure du match
il y avait décidé de prendre le carte ça
je suis pas sûr par contre
pas sûr de ce choix
tu as peut-être H4 un moment donné pour
ouvrir un petit peu les lignes sur le
roi noir
une position quand même
plus facile à jouer pour les blancs les
noirs du mal à faire quelque chose avec
le dame
ça c'est un petit peu mal place mal
passé quand même pour
les plus mais on sent que
on voit vraiment que que
[Musique]
le fou G7 qui qui généralement c'est de
la mauvaise pièce tu vois il a pas été
changé là l'idée ça pourrait être
cavalier pour jouer le fou en H6 essayer
de d'échanger des pièces difficiles
[Musique]
je ne pense pas
est-ce qu'il y a du changement au niveau
des scènes
moi j'ai ça c'est la seule scène que
j'ai avec caméra après je tourne parce
que j'ai mis j'ai dupliquer les scènes
pour avoir toutes les caméras et pas
avoir à changer à chaque fois
manuellement donc j'ai cette chaîne là
après j'ai d'autres scènes mais on voit
pas les joueurs donc après faut voir
mais j'ai quoi encore comme ça
on nous voit nous
tu devrais mettre en pause coupé
le stream de peut-être des Américains je
sais pas si ça te fait chez moi la guêpe
sur ton écran en haut dans le coin
[Musique]
je suis là et sinon je suis là mais sans
rien du coup
c'est bien comme tu étais a priori ouais
[Musique]
donc j'ai pas d'autres mieux
fait du coup Hikaru dans cette partie il
regarde le ciel
une position compliquée il a un pion de
moins
et pouvoir comment ça s'est passé
on s'est arrêté là
c'est 3 prises
pour 4 tours
donc il a un beau fou en B2 qui est très
très mauvais
c'est clair que les noirs
mais il s'active
on en est là et c'est une partie qui est
chaude et j'ai chaudes
je comprends pas trop
le cavalier j'imagine
est pas très bon
toujours
c'est là tu vas perdre l'option 4 en fin
de variante
ou pas d'ailleurs ou pas parce que du
coup il y a un mec du couloir à un site
qui traîne si jamais je mange là
mais bon la pollution c'est au moins
égale et il faut
f6es dans cette ronde
pour prendre et tout en l'air que se
passe-t-il
il a plus de temps j'avais pas vu la 40
secondes
la cavalue 7 il prend je prends la haut
d'ailleurs ça la partie et si il
mangeait ici et ben je mange là puis je
mangeais la pièce donc après par la
qualité plutôt que de perdre la pièce
qu'il a il a pas fait une bonne partie
honnêtement il a rien fait non et il
profite d'une gaffe assez grossière de
you et donc quand même ça prouve que ce
G6 est un peu bizarre s'il avait joué
juste fou F6 ouais ça avait l'air sur
d'autres mieux en plus quoi et on voit
que Samy vautidoff ah bah tu chantes on
le voit à droite dans les scores et oui
et on va aller voir ça de ce pas les
chevaliers de Gotham c'est des
chevaliers ou des cavaliers d'ailleurs
c'est un autre interprétation
[Musique]
je propose quand même d'aller voir les
parties en fin de stream enfin de rondes
et après on aura toujours un petit peu
de temps il y a toujours un petit délai
entre les entre les 7 on aura le temps
d'aller voir les parties encore la
conversion mais à partir mais bon
maintenant c'est lui qui presse quoi il
va défendre là il va mettre un petit
pion en deux mettre le roi ici et voir
ce qui se passe quoi
mais c'est vrai que bon c'est quand même
difficile à gagner cette position
normalement
oui
en C5 et c'est de consolider ouais
pas du tout les choix de
tour de 5 secondes ou pas
qui joue très très mal cette partie on
peut le dire là ouais c'est le temps le
temps qu'il mais après tu vois c'est
qu'on l'a dit l'autre jour quand on joue
contre l'avoir en fait c'est incroyable
c'est bien Samir Robin l'auteur
de son niveau je vais aussi mal cette
finale c'est assez incroyable une
première gare une deuxième sur des
tactiques comme assez évidente
mais quand tu es en face de ma carte
toujours j'ai l'impression un petit peu
le bras qui tremble c'est pas comment il
va te voler
tu sais que ça va arriver
mais tu sais pas comment c'est bizarre
pour le coup il a donné le bâton pour se
faire battre Léo c'est ça la cave
franchement
c'est plus sûr qu'a perdu
comment fait-on pour visualiser toutes
les cases de l'échiquier c'est tout
alors tu veux dire les coordonnées je
pense c'est connaître les cases
de l'échiquier resto je sais qu'il les a
les a par cœur moi non quand il était
petit non
[Musique]
vrai c'est
toujours en club tu fais des parties tu
prends l'habitude de noter tu verras que
ça viendra tout seul donc c'est pas du
tout difficile
de noter c'est vrai que sur Internet
pour les gens qui jouent que sur
Internet peut-être c'est moins intuitif
après c'est pas non plus quelque chose
d'obligatoire
[Musique]
c'est pas important de les connaître
ça facilite parfois la lecture de livres
d'articles ou dans des vidéos quand les
gens commentent mais
peut-on sortir sans les connaître
après il y a une
c'est quoi c'est comme moi il y a une
section tu peux tu as un truc les cases
et les couleurs et tout c'est une
section si tu veux t'entraîner pour
apprendre des cases attention
tu peux tu as des casques qui sont
affichés il faut que tu cliques le plus
possible sur la case
cette année
cette perspective non
c'est pas du tout ça
entraînement
salut François Jacques bienvenue
et vision merci j'ai lu Paul c'est ça
ça me fait ça me fait un peu peur quand
même pour la
cavalier B5 et prend ses Celtes il y a
pas de contre-jour très technique
une belle option au gothams
oui bah c'est un très bon site aussi pas
de problème
non non je plie sur lichen je peux même
dire de moi je vais pas me faire ban
vous inquiétez pas
on boycote pas mais c'est vrai que on
stream pour chat.com donc imagine bien
que on va pas faire la pub non plus de
cette plateforme c'est juste ça
on peut jouer de façon sur plusieurs
plateformes
les avantages par rapport à Jess par
exemple s'il y a beaucoup plus de
contenu notamment pas mal d'articles il
y a plus de vidéos les leçons il y a
plus d'outils aussi quand même
d'entraînement même si les pièces des
enfants aussi
pour tous les goûts toute façon et puis
il prend son temps
qu'elle va dépenser 7 ça va être abandon
le pion a qui va courir à dame
elle se bat
beaucoup plus
forte que
[Musique]
ça veut rien dire je ressemble
oui il faut encore un petit peu de
technique parce que elle a réussi à
bloquer le pion right son food donc elle
se bat bien et plus beaucoup de temps
pour pour ça donc je vous avais dit
Robson qui d'ailleurs j'ai pas changé
les noms pour Robson qui
qui est souvent diagnost d'ailleurs
et décidé de recycler son cavalier alors
vers où il va qu'il fasse attention à
son pion A5 obligé de jouer Damien pour
le protéger mais
maintenant peut-être la joueuse Casa qui
va essayer d'envoyer son pion h son jeu
pas encore fait cette partie
c'est pas encore fait attention
mais il va forcément devoir changer
peut-être le roi on va à 4 peut-être une
bonne idée d'une heure défendre avec le
roi et puis surtout
qu'elle a très très fort
et puis on a été donné
attention quand même hein
tu prends le temps je vais pousser mon
pion très loin très vite
je pense qu'il a réussi oui il a réussi
une erreur dans ma carte échec ça c'est
sûr elle doit revenir à 7 pour bloquer
mais maintenant la dame est trop passive
mais bon attention qu'il y a ce pion qui
peut courir quand même
mais oui il va le faire ça maintenant
[Musique]
à jouer et baisse défense en tout cas
3-1 dans ce set pour les Gotham Knights
qui prennent une belle option en ce
match donc du coup tu voulais voir les
parties donc bon Nakamura on s'en fout
on n'avait déjà vu donc félo seghe on
s'était arrêté du coup
sur une autre scène on va se mettre
celle là donc du coup
voilà il a joué de couteau on était à B4
c'est bien ça il y a eu ouais
et du coup l'idée c'est de jouer sur le
long terme à main cette poussée à un
moment le pion en C5 donc il m'a préparé
ici des cavalles en B3 qui était en
prise du coup
tour c'est de on prépare jusqu'au bout
la dame
donc ça c'est un peu mystérieux par
contre pourquoi pas et c'est ça pur en
prise après un prise et avec avaler
prendre des 5 donc après le tour de deux
maintenant il y a plus de problème
dessus
cavalier 7 a été joué c'est 6 ouais
là c'est où tout se passe bien
les Noirs ils ont mis en place aucun
contrôle
à 5 le cavalier il va se retrouver en A8
quoi
un cadre fou B5 avec attaque là et une
découverte sur la tour qui fait que du
coup la dame est enfermée aussi et donc
on est obligé de perdre la tour en 8 qui
est dramatique
c'est une prise qui est tombée donc
récupérer mais bon
il y a pas eu de match dans cette partie
et du coup donc le champ clan walkido
qui était hyper intéressant donc le roi
il se fait mater en H3 on s'est arrêté
du coup après faut prendre F6
ah oui la même pas manger la tourte
parce que surprise il y a d'un point
échec
et du coup
tout bouge et ben donc avaler les trois
le retour
il a récupéré et il a deux pions de plus
voilà donc c'est un massacre dans cette
partie ça marche
[Musique]
voir que je ne connaissais pas il s'est
présenté clairement mais bon mais il a
il a gagné les Olympiens avec son équipe
donc il est déjà là de base
c'est impressionnant
alors pour cette ronde 3 je vais vous la
fiche je vais
à pied alors attends je vais les mettre
en direct pour ne pas oublier le truc
tac tac du coup alors on va avoir du
coup
un Robson avec les Blancs
contre
Hikaru Nakamura donc là ça y est ça va
être les gros gros chocs
il va falloir être solide
mais du coup maintenant que qu'il y a un
avantage à Oscar peut-être que du coup
c'est l'équipe des Gotham Knights qui
peuvent être un peu plus enfin qui
peuvent jouer un peu plus solides
chanclan
[Musique]
chanclan avec les plans du coup un plan
qui doit se racheter
sans clan qui du coup aura les
blancs contre
Vladimir fedoceïev
dans cette troisième partie
et on a encore une partie qui s'annonce
assez déséquilibrée sur le papier vu ce
que vient de nous montrer vos idoff là
il a les blancs contre Zoé Tang qui est
en grande difficulté depuis le début de
ce match elle avait encore affronté un
joueur beaucoup mieux que séquelles et
avec le noir ça monte difficile mais
peut-être qu'elle va réussir un petit
peu à
se détendre ouais
donc là du coup vos kids qui a des
blancs ou entre sauvetang ça va être
difficile
et derrière on a au dernier chéquier
alors
hop
on va avoir
nurmanova
avec les Blancs
contre un Christopher qui était en
petite forme qu'on a qu'un qui avait une
bonne partie et qui
s'est saboté ouais alors du coup je
change juste ça
[Musique]
les licornes se rebiffent ou pas c'est
ça
du coup 53 là on voit qu'il y a encore
des appareils sur le sur le stream mais
vous allez voir que ça va changer dans
très peu de temps moi je cherche là la
ronde 3 qui devrait pas tarder à arriver
mais on a une pause à Paris en tout cas
un tournoi spécial on me dit dans le
chat le 24 mars
le 24 mars
une arène royale et les Playa qui auront
lieu en
mais j'ai pas suivi c'est quoi cette
Arena et puis exactement le format c'est
vraiment un truc à part je crois que
chaque équipe doit pouvoir faire jouer à
mon avis 4 joueurs je pense que c'est
limité et c'est
pour les joueurs de oui c'est le joueur
et à la fin on va additionner leurs
points et ce corrompus de points
et qui prend portera l'emportera l'Arena
et puis les joueurs de la même équipe ne
peuvent pas s'affronter les uns les
autres bien sûr bien sûr et je connais
depuis le format exact mais ça remonte
un
pour les playoffs il y aura l'équipe
Blitz
mais la route est longue
est-ce que tu as vu le cas de triche
qui est sorti hier il y a eu un nouveau
code triche où je viens de Roumanie j'ai
lu un article
j'ai vu un truc sur Facebook comme quoi
un joueur avait laissé un téléphone sans
carte SIM dans les toilettes
et ils ont fouillé ce téléphone et ils
ont trouvé une adresse mail qui était
qui était associé au téléphone ou contre
d'échec qui était ouverte avec sa
position en cours oui mais après ça peut
être les blancs les noirs en fait donc
Google
mais en fait moi je peux Morgan
hotmail.fr et je vais laisser aux
toilettes et puis je peux dire que c'est
toi aussi en fait mais bon
il peut se défendre comme ça mais c'est
un peu ça là
ça va être facile à démonter quand même
je pense ah oui
que c'était son téléphone ça qui est
assez souffle est un vrai nom mais en
fait quand je l'ai quand je l'ai quand
j'ai eu l'article je me suis dit ouais
ok mais parce qu'en fait je suis au
courant d'un cas de triche qui s'est
passé
salut Eva ça fait longtemps on voit que
je t'ai pas vu
comment vas-tu
non en fait j'ai vu une idée
une idée de triche c'était toi de
Benidorm
Espagne tu as deux tournois en Espagne
tu as le tournoi plus de 2000 et moins
de 2000 avec beaucoup d'argent je crois
que le temps moins de 2000 il donne 3 ou
4500 euros au premier je crois très gros
prix par catégorie hello donc forcément
pour les joueurs amateurs et il y avait
un joueur
d'ailleurs le cas je crois que c'était
en fait avec un français il me semble il
y avait un
[Musique]
comment ça se fait l'histoire
il y aura un Français dans l'histoire je
crois un joueur qui a mis un téléphone
dans la poche de son adversaire
pour les personnes pour le faire sonner
vraiment un truc de rat
et après son téléphone sonne il fait non
c'est pas moi j'imagine il a pété un
câble et en fait ils sont rendus compte
que le téléphone c'est un téléphone
étranger et de la même nationalité que
l'adversaire peut-être c'était imaginons
un Français contre un Serbe et mec j'ai
un téléphone sert vraiment pas un moment
donné écoute enfin s'il te plaît quoi tu
vois et après je sais plus ce qui s'est
passé c'était il y a très longtemps mais
il est tellement d'argent j'ai en fait
que les gens sont mais c'était marrant
enfin marrant non c'est pas marrant mais
du coup comme je suis contre cette
histoire
un mec etc bah en fait moi je la prends
parce que j'ai pensé en fait ok en fait
je peux me faire avoir quoi je peux me
faire hacker tu vois
c'est que le mec qui trichait il se fait
prendre pendant la 25 mais il avait 0,5
sur 4
il a perdu contre 2200 2000 et je veux
des joueurs plus forts quoi ils perdent
1900 il fait nul contre un 1500 il fait
que des contre-performants et il a été
pris en train de tricher du coup contre
un 1200 donc c'est à dire qu'ils ont
vraiment trois catastrophes
bref peu importe
ce que tu fais juste
la triche de l'échec c'est juste c'est
juste pas possible c'est pour ça que les
arrêts un petit décalage de plus en plus
dans les tournois là le tournoi qui a
lieu en Allemagne en ce moment je sais
pas si tu as eu bon il y a le délai de
15 minutes qui devient apparemment la
norme il y a le scanner aussi enfin
détecteur de
de métaux ils ont rajouté un autre truc
qui passe un espèce d'aimant au niveau
de l'oreille
pour vérifier si tu as pas une
micro-oreillette une puce dans l'oreille
un nouveau truc franchement ce que ce
que ce que tu dois faire maintenant pour
être sûr que les gens font faire payer
jusqu'au bout c'est c'est vrai que c'est
c'est dur quoi en fait parce que
maintenant elle est présente partout
quoi c'est juste ouf quoi c'est clair
tu arrives au monde de la troisième
ronde avec un troisième ronde
pour les chevaliers de Gotham qui ont
fait une trou alors juste là c'est une
sorte un peu chelou avec A6 et fougères
je connais les idées tu vois en fait
donc là c'est c'est mais je pense que
depuis le début
ma caille il est en troll un pur troll
en toutes les parties parce que là H6
c'est la nouveauté
mais c'est vrai qu'ici je veux fujicat
c'est assez standard l'idée c'est de
jouer à un moment donné avec un cavalan
C6 jouer au 5 et en fait quand tu
l'ouvrage en F3 pour installer un
cavalier en D4 c'est un peu l'idée mais
mais à 6 bon après à 6 dans cette année
c'est jamais un coup qui est qui est
jamais inutile tu vois il y a toujours
du B5 même C6 B5 mais c'est vrai que 2 à
6 c'est drôle pourra servir plus tard
mais ouais
qui aime bien jouer à 3 à 6
je suis pas sûr qu'il joue à trois dans
la période quand même mais
à trois dans le salon c'est quand même
assez
pardon non c'est pas possible
mais
c'est optimiste ouais cavalier à 5 c'est
plus dans l'idée
en fait sur B5 il va y avoir C5
non non en fait ça c'est plus ou moins
théorique c'est position mais du coup
être option à 7 j'ai l'impression
b3c5 et en fait toujours pour B5
derrière très souvent
un peu comme à Benko si tu veux mais bon
voilà et donc c'est ça que c'est hyper
thématique
[Musique]
aussi même à 3
bk3 donc je me dis qu'il y a un truc
comme ça j'étais du dambie 6 alors
peut-être c'est pas forcément l'idée
mais l'idée tu vois ce que j'aurais
voulu faire c'est mettre un Caval en B3
D4 ça aurait été génial
mais du coup les gars qui va être
violent
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
peut-être que V5
après peut-être dame C7 autour C8 qui
est dans pas si débile l'idée de P4
essayer de manger ces quatre c'est aussi
un thème
si jamais vraiment si simple de jeu BK
[Musique]
c'est la partie je pense pour ces 8
dame là j'aime moins parce que tu vois
après il y aura un vis-à-vis je suis un
peu moins fan
mes tours C8 m'a l'air complètement
[Musique]
B8 mais ça paraît
autoriser donc
j'ai pas le temps de la bouger regardez
d'imbécités
qui fait très mal bêtise je pars par
Naka par contre là je suis étonné
son temps ah oui mais du coup à moins
qu'il a ah d'accord je pense que j'ai
compris l'idée sur B4 il veut sûrement
faire un truc du style alors je sais pas
en quel sens mais l'idée c'est que si je
veux cavaler B7 plus tard il peut avoir
envie de jouer prises prise et A5 voilà
qui est thématique l'idée en jouant un
coup je peux rencontrer l'idée c'est
qu'à pas pris esprit c'est à 5 en fait
et ben j'ai récupéré la case c'est 5
pour mon Caval plus tard
on a vu notamment dans la première
partie donc peut-être que donc je sais
pas si tu mets cette d'abord ou si tu
manges une fois et tout ça et que tu
sois à 5 et
ouais parce que si tu prends prends
peut-être ça
qui peut être très relou ah il y a
peut-être mais bon ok à voir il y a un
peu tout en prise elle est assez vite en
fait cette position c'est compliqué
[Musique]
la prise en B4
après bon il y a toujours du P5 mais bon
c'est un peu comme un Benco tu vas
tourner des pions pour avoir le colonne
mais ça m'a l'air un petit peu bizarre
très vite mais la pression au temps
ouais donc en fait bon lui je pense
qu'il s'en fout un peu la pression
mais bon c'est vrai que ça peut
un petit tour surtout pour voir comment
ça se passe
donc je fais le petit tour à changer les
noms après
trois quatre cinq six trois quatre cinq
six ok donc position
c'est une position
standard il y a le pire des cinq qui est
sous pression ici
chez les Blancs on n'a pas envie de
manger F600
du coup à moins que si tu peux tu peux
le manger ou pas
avec deux tactifié sur H2 à la fin
l'idée c'est que si je mange tout
croiser une pièce mais attention Easter
stuff est là faut prendre H2 et
d'apprendre des 5 c'est 15 la dame donc
en fait
c'est quoi la le petit truc alors il y a
peut-être des idées des fois avec
cavalier 5 aussi hein
je suis en forme aujourd'hui
[Musique]
moi je sais pas convaincu de tout je
sais pas à mon avis peut-être il y a des
idées
tactiles je sais pas si les Noirs
prennent des 5 ça peut être un peu
dangereux aussi
par exemple j'ai pas de cavaler H7 bon
ça marche jamais je crois que dame 5 je
vais le montrer
une fourchette qui pourrait presque
avoir lieu en vrai que c'est défendu
comme ça ça marcherait pas à cause de
dame 5 qui menace maths et qui me permet
de bouger ma tour derrière et le
guerrier sera trouver ridicule en H7 et
sur F4 j'ai chèque quelque part là où là
et ensuite pareil je bouge ma tour et le
cavalier serait ridicule en H7
donc ça marche pas il y a eu toro1 H6
c'est vrai qu'achu c'est un comportant
une fenêtre pour le roi ça empêche
et ce pion dessin qui sera mangé
peut-être plus tard
mais
je sais pas c'est que les prend des 5
j'étais quand même du four au 4 car
quand même pas mal
avec ces pièces empilées sur la colonne
des il y a plusieurs couches
ça peut être dangereux de le manger ce
pion mais c'est pas forcément évident à
accueillir c'est pas si concret il va
installer un caillou F5 très intéressant
le choix de
elle va être la pression sur G7 H6 D6
sur case noir et vous créez des petits
thèmes autour du roi
la case F5 c'est toujours une très belle
case pour un cavalier si on peut les
stabiliser généralement ça crée de gros
danger
on va aller voir si tu veux les
rapidement les trois et quatre
qui qui pose de gros problèmes à Tang ça
on l'a vu tu vois
que c'est mal passé là
il y a beaucoup de mal à exister depuis
le début de ce match
cavalier B5
là il faut que je crois déjà
[Musique]
je sais plus ce qu'il faut jouer là
mais cette ligne elle est elle est elle
est pas simple
pas du tout naturel
donc là je déteste elle a pas envie de
se prendre un D4 qui perdrait si le fou
bouge et qu'elle prend des 6 du coup D3
elle perd un pion mais au moins elle a
le temps de croquer
je le 5 pour garder mon cavalier en D6
je pense que c'est déjà perdu hein Samy
je pense sur le papier
de mettre les caméras
voilà
et du coup dans la partie du match c'est
celle-là avec du coup
nur MANOVA avec les Blancs contre you
3 4 5 6 donc là il y a un pion de plus
pour les Noirs mais une position
d'attaque
peut tomber aussi
mais là je pense que les noirs sont très
très bien elle est très solide et je
vais être en D8 fois F6 et changer des
pièces
et le Cavalier Blanc qui a pas de cadre
au centre
ça pourrait être intéressant mais là
j'ai même pas d'option en fait
je pense que je
soutiennes qui font respecter
normalement
c'est quand même la partie peut-être à
regarder avec Champlan aussi c'est les
deux grosses parties comment la réaction
à 5 B5 qui se cavalier qu'il compte
remettre en place plus tard
tranquillement
pour prendre des cases les cases noires
notamment cassé 5 pour son cavalier on
va aussi finalement F4 qui sera en prise
donc foutez 4 qui a l'air d'être un très
bon coup qui a peut-être été raté un par
option
c'est un coup un peu invisible tu as
l'impression que ça perd un pion de
partout et ici qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on joue dans E5 ça donne un case des
cinq c'est très moche
c'est pas forcément une option mais si
tu prends là plus tard tu peux avoir
l'option qui est faible ici mais je suis
encore le cavalier F7
il y a je des 5 il ouvre tout ah oui
il met quand même un sacré bordel sur
les chéquiers avec tous les pions en
prison au centre ouais il a plus de
temps la pendule position est compliqué
il a raison de de vue comme ça et là il
menace vous voyez d'un point F4 on a
l'impression en fait que c'est défendu
par le fou mais le Fou est cloué par mon
fou
donc d'un point F4
gagnerait un peu en plus des problèmes
ce serait catastrophique pour les blancs
donc là il va se montrer très précis
alors c'est quoi la bonne réaction ce
que vous avez deux qui peut être pas mal
on s'enlève du visa villa
exactement de faire une fourchette tu
peux me montrer
moi j'aurais pu manger
au minimum je prends le pion F4 et ça se
passe quand même plutôt bien
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire E5 ou
justement ce qu'il y a cette fourchette
aussi
et ça
pour les plantes
ou pas ouais
qui reste une minute 47 contre 3,50 de
et donc c'est quoi il prend la tour OK
cette position
les coups blancs ont l'air plus dur à
trouver que les coups noirs
pour les blancs surtout quand en face
c'est un cauchemar parce qu'on a qu'à
lui les calculs il va pas trop trop les
faire mais regarde tu es une pièce qui
va être un cavalier en fond en dessin
c'est un truc comme ça par exemple voir
fouder 5 mais après il y a le pion G4
qui peut être en l'air
quand même pour ton roi tu vois avec le
pion G4 avec ça avec aussi les cavaliers
qui arrivent parce que moi aussi tu vois
j'ai la case des quatre qui peut arriver
aussi
mais bon ok la jauge on voit que elle
l'aime bien les blancs il se passe quoi
donc surprise en Russie là il faut être
concret là
tu veux jouer ouais
j'ai quand même échec peut-être
mais à chaque fois ce que je propose
tu donnes
en fait je sais pas je calcule pas
depuis c'est bien que je calcule pas
mais ça avait l'air passé simple on voit
qu'il y a plein de thèmes en tout cas
tactiques
j'ai pensé
mais sans voir du tout la suite donc
ce que tu coupes le fou des cartes en
fait c'est hyper malin
cavalier 2 qui a un coup normal
ça c'est totalement dans son style et
puis généralement
c'est ton point fort tu joues quoi du
coup tu manges une pièce je mange juste
là et je mange là j'ai une pièce
d'avance
la tour avec fourchette royale et quand
on la bouche ça avec la dame enfin ça a
l'air vraiment perdu en fait
quand je te reprends F3 cavaler prendre
des quatre tu m'as dit mais j'ai tout
reprend un effet intermédiaire
cette opportunité et ce qui fait que les
Blancs finalement il reste avec la paire
de fou contre la paire de cavaliers la
position en train de s'ouvrir
très chaud les chevaux c'est hyper chaud
il y a 10 secondes à la pendule pour les
blancs contre 2 minutes 34 de Nakamura
contre Nakamura ça c'est extrêmement dur
hein ça a mis il faut être précis
jusqu'au bout
la diagonale noire elle fait peur aussi
se fout Arthur c'est la place à la dame
ça peut être très chaud cette partie
elle est décisive se trouve pour la
l'issue de ce match parce que
deux points maintenant bon
G2 mais par exemple tu vois sur un truc
comme ça un cavalier G7 pour défendre on
peut voir un tour de 4 à arriver
à la caméra j'ai vu Robson qui avait
l'air d'avoir manifester un petit peu
son mécontentement mais pourtant il a
quelqu'un qui est content je crois qu'il
a une idée tu vois Eurêka
pour pas se faire ma tête
et quand il mange tout la fin il est
père ici et il a tout mangé peut-être
pas le bon choix pour ça il a plus de
temps la pendule c'est extrêmement dur
mais pour gagner en tout cas c'était le
mieux je pense pour échanger parce que
ce fou est trop fort contre la Casa
promotion
à la caméra
contrôle les cases d'échecs de la tour
en baby enfin c'est horrible
aussi
a beaucoup de réussite alors c'est la
provoque aussi mais sur ce match
et maintenant parlable
c'est ouf
qui va être un peu dégoûté je pense
c'est une partie intéressante un très
chaude très très chaude il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de ratés là si on
regarde la fiche sur piècecom il y a du
rouge de partout mais bon c'est normal
c'est normal
est-ce que tu peux remettre juste on
regardera après peut-être
Champlan on va aller voir rapidement ce
qui se passe chez chanclan et attention
parce que il y a 7 3 virtuellement il
manque plus que un point et demi
pour
assurer la victoire et Jean-Claude qui a
l'air pas très bien non
il y a 20 secondes pour les Noirs quand
même
attention F2 aussi ça peut être une idée
aussi
alors politique je sais pas s'il a vu le
kugaillon après cours ça je pense qu'il
était dégoûté surtout parce qu'il s'est
rendu compte de la tactique et qui se
faisait Chloé qui perdait le fou dans la
finale
je pense c'est surtout ça qu'il a
dégoûté
mais on regardera quand la route sera
finie on reviendra pendant l'impôt sur
la partie pour voir justement comment il
aurait pu continuer l'attaque c'était
intéressant
pour pour l'équipe de Gotham et oui
parce que du coup Naka qui part Hopson
et du coup fait le CF qui
qui joue solide et qui perd pas du coup
ça va être je pense un Samy des chances
que le match soit quasiment plié en fait
déjà
donc ça fait nul d'ailleurs à l'instant
et
Christopher pour les licornes pour les
maintenir en vie qui était favoris mais
qui joue encore là
le résultat
[Musique]
plus vite que mon cerveau
dans le temps on avait vu qu'il avait
une position
gagnante avec les noirs
un peu plus loin
à faire abstraction à fermer
le champ de son cerveau où il y a juste
le score de ce match de cette pour ne
pas
me spoil je ne veux pas de spoil
je suis prêt à fermer les yeux
et il a raté une fourchette royale
[Musique]
qui est mignon surprise il y a un match
du couloir
tamassette avec du coup menace de maths
à l'étouffer un cavaillage 3e
tout le monde connaît je peux encore le
chat hop même fatoumodo est-ce que tout
le monde l'a déjà placé parce que ça
fait toujours très plaisir quand on
arrive à le placer on dit
en tout cas ça m'arrive en partie lente
je me souviens la première fois j'étais
j'étais Benjamin au minimes écouter
jeune j'avais joué en
un jeune j'étais je l'ai placé j'étais
hyper content
[Musique]
parce que
on a déjà fait quoi
la technique pousse les pions et on va
encore gagner B2 vraiment très propre
donc tu voulais voir la partie tout à
l'heure tu voulais revenir sur la partie
de de
Naka
on va revenir sur le petit Naka
rapidement dans sa mise tu es bien je
vais essayer de mettre tes caméras en
même temps pour
pas perdre de temps pour la prochaine
c'était à quel moment que tu voulais
voir c'était ici non peut-être au moment
de l'échange un peu plus loin au moins
il a changé la dame en plus
encore un peu plus loin
ouais
je crois que c'est le coup d'après voilà
c'est là il a fait dame troncailler
alors est-ce que ce qui a transmission
dans cette finale qui aurait dû être nul
qui n'avait pas gaffe
ensuite mais ici ce qui avait mieux pour
les blancs pour maintenir la tension
est-ce qu'il pouvait pas peut-être juste
reculer le fou
c'est pas parce que c'est pas bon du
tout d'ailleurs
je réponds pas c'est normal je te mets
la caméra
un coup de cavalier d'accord
ok
mais c'est une partie comme on l'a dit
je rentre direct très très compliqué
avec peu de temps la pendule quasiment
impossible d'avoir un jeu parfait ici
et donc ouais peut-être le bon coup
c'est de reculer le fou le fou de gaz
blanche qui est attaqué
même laissé potentiellement les tours
s'échanger c'est pas grave et
de se dire tu as toujours ton cavalier
au centre attaqué
[Musique]
bah pour enlever la petite attaqué tout
simplement et donc admettons que tous
ces changements
donc ça a l'air très très fort
ok bah il y aura un truc avant encore
assez possible effectivement
ok bah c'est là ouvrir option on a raté
sa chance mais encore une fois c'était
vraiment difficile mais cette défaite
elle fait très mal un gars qui a trois
sur trois on avait parlé en début de
stream et ce qui allait faire 4 sur 4
on avait jeté que c'était possible
mais il reste à affronter son clan du
coup c'est ça dans la partie
et avec les Blancs
avec des blancs
le match va pas dire qu'il est plié
parce qu'on a vu un des remontées
de deux points et qui avait réussi lors
de la première semaine à arracher des
partages on a eu les
commentaires je crois les bras qui
menaient 6 et demi et qui ont perdu
8 dernières parties
d'affilée
ils ont perdu les 7 parties d'affilée
dans le trou dans dans le troisième max
et ben il y avait une partie qui avait
été perdue pour eux ok qui faisait un
score peut-être si cette nuit après
toutes les autres parties donc les trois
du match plus les quatre prochaines ont
été perdues avec notamment
trois coups vous avez peut-être vu
passer
trois coups qui était quand même assez
facile
pour lui c'est très très simple très
simple
je vais mettre en colère alors si 45
c'est le deuxième poule la combinaison
mais il l'a vu après avoir joué
en fait quand il a joué dommage et je
crois qu'il l'a vu en juin
cette semaine oui un maths en Inde qui a
été raté par des
joueurs c'était des 26 50
tu mets de la dame à côté du roi
tu vois faut pas faire confiance à
l'adversaire des fois juste
un coup tu vois tu vois ce que c'est
tout ou pas non mais après des histoires
de m'attendre un coup ça il y en a plein
quand tu vois même tu as vu par exemple
le match il y avait comment il s'appelle
c'était cramique qui faisait un match
contre l'ordinateur je sais plus quel
arrondissait je crois que c'était
peut-être
[Musique]
et du coup menacé de la marche 7 et
cramique il a raté pas mal en fait on a
un coup
une partie lente hein bon après c'était
quoi
mais ça arrive les matins comme ça on
est humain avant tout
donc ouais mais par contre
même là sur internet ça arrive qui n'a
pas raté dans sa vie
sur internet fait tout le monde pour le
coup en vrai je pense pas avoir déjà
mon plus gros vol mon plus gros vol de
toute ma carrière et ben ce n'est pas ce
lieu qu'on arrive à sa vie détrompe-toi
j'avais joué une qualité et une tour de
moi contrairement à 1900 euros et en
fait et ben il y a un match en deux
coups pour lui
mais bon c'était pas très dur à voir
c'est une sorte de ma télé tout fait un
peu bizarre qui est en attendant
imparable
[Musique]
vous avez vu il m'a seule chance c'est
de mettre la pression quoi et en vente
tempo tempo tempo à la fin
il tremblait il a continué je t'aime pas
avant de se poser beaucoup de temps la
pendule
vous avez du temps prenez-le quand vous
êtes sûrs
le problème c'est que j'ai le trait et
que je l'ai battais en premier mais il
pouvait mater avec échec échec mat et il
l'a pas fait et quand j'ai gagné ça
j'avais j'avais entendu
pour ceux qui suivent un peu de temps
sur
il est très bon sur le Blitz
la recherche
et pas beaucoup de temps
un lien qui
m'a envoyé le lien d'une
position de la partie non
regarde ton lien tu m'as envoyé il y a
marqué analyse et du coup moi quand je
clique dessus j'ai une salle d'analyse
vide
et c'est bon oui
et alors du coup qu'est-ce que c'est un
c'est une sorte de 6e j'ai l'impression
avec un grand rock qui a été joué par
par chanclan donc champ clan qui est qui
serait en train de faire all-in
peut-être contre Naka il y a pas le
choix il a gagné même avec les noirs
on voit pas souvent un grand rock dans
la sicilienne
c'est pour moi de jamais vu ici
non pas forcément
[Musique]
il a quand même le pion en H3
incroyable
ou je fais une histoire d'abandon alors
que tu avais pas vu quelque chose comme
ça non mais des abandons alors que alors
que alors que faut pas du tout
abandonner
[Musique]
alors qu'il est pas perdu
noir contre pion blanc ici je crois et
son roi était là il y avait une histoire
en fait il pouvait se cache avec son roi
pour se tâter c'est contre qui c'est sûr
[Musique]
pas perdre
et il était
pas si loin de faire nul mais il est
fait encore du boulot mais il veut pour
la nul mais là ils sont primo il a perdu
la partie direct c'était contre la
Géorgie aux Olympiades
il a fait un primov t'as pas vu ça si
j'ai vu justement il a joué un coup sans
regarder ce que je veux c'est un peu
comme toi
tu es parti en Serbie
un peu mais qui a gagné contre un enfant
de 12 ans qui avait 2200 hello il a
gagné en 7 coups espagnols avec le pion
B5 qui tape le fou l'adversaire il a
fait petit rock et ça a mis B prend un 4
merci c'est une partie officielle partie
lente
[Musique]
ok alors on fait un petit peu le tour
rapidement
alors fais dodo
il joue contre Robson avec les Blancs
donc pollution un peu comme tout à
l'heure on avait dit donc là il y a
plein plein de choses à faire cette
pollution donc il y a le fou des trois
qui va être sûrement pris à un moment
donné nous donnera la paire de feu au
noir avec tout le monde de fou c'est 6
mais une pollution des blancs assez
agréable des poussées F5 ou à 5 donc là
il peut se passer un peu n'importe quoi
ça
ils sont obligés de jouer pour le gain
tous les deux avec les Noirs
à cause de la situation du match ils
sont obligés de forcer un peu le jeu
quoi
là il faut qu'ils mettent trois
aiguilles sur 4 en fait pour gagner
match
et 4 sur 4 pour le coiffeur poteau ce
serait ce serait beau
alors Christopher roux rapidement
contre
vos Kid of donc ça c'est ça c'est une
Espagnole assez connue
c'est position avec 4
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
[Musique]
il a pas peur on a vu un pokédex ça a
l'air d'être un joueur très agressif il
envoie prend sa chance
OK dans la partie entre les fils donc
jusqu'à tout perdu
ce qui est normal
de Hello puisque vraiment elles avaient
des adversaires beaucoup mieux classés
mais voilà Nova nous a fait une
meilleure impression
c'est la confirme regarde le temps on se
trouve 9 minutes à 3
donc en grande souffrance depuis le
début il y a une pièce de plus va il y a
une qualité de plus pour les pour les
blancs mais les cases noires c'est vrai
que elles sont hyper ouvertes qui peut
arriver avec foodé 4 ou même l'action
[Musique]
à la mode F3
H5 G5
[Musique]
prise on a pu passer en H
et la part de fou blanche qui joue pas
si bien que ça tout refaire OK
n'est pas obligé d'apprendre d'ailleurs
la tour dans l'absolu mais on peut
essayer de la prendre des fois
je pense que tout RAV4 bon c'est
peut-être du coup elle a trouvé
elle-même mais je pense que les idées
les avaient déjà elle a pas trouvé ça je
pense toute seule comme ça
serait surprenant
en pratique je pense
il y a des trous
est-ce que je peux manger les deux côtés
il faudrait tremblement de terre pas
forcément très heureux de ma part
j'aime beaucoup les noirs et voilà je me
fais attaquer
voilà une invité mystère
bien les Noirs mais bon c'est pas simple
encore c'est tu vois c'est une qualité
de plus du coup si je joue un peu
imprécie ça peut vite se retourner en
fait donc il faut qu'on continue c'est
pas encore fait
quand même beaucoup de casse blanche qui
emmuré derrière sa structure de pion
le roi qui est plus faible en fait au
niveau du matériel tu vois je mange des
pions quand même
donc c'est pas clair
il peut arriver un jour
mais ça peut être une idée aussi si je
bouge de ces pièces là il y a foi je
crois qu'il peut arriver aussi c'est
franchement
pas encore facile
fouder 3 dans le chat
plutôt jouer avec la qualité de moi et
l'attaque ou le matériel et même de
manière générale plutôt vous pouvez
gérer le matériel à tout prix peut-être
devoir défendre et souffrir
l'initiative c'est ça plutôt la question
trop gourmand ou est-ce qu'on préfère
attaquer
[Musique]
mais
ta question
est-ce que tu préfères plutôt
potentiellement l'avantage matériel mais
de voir subir la TAC
initiative adverse ou être le camp
justement qui qui va sacrifier des pions
des qualités pour pour l'initiative et
pour attaquer
le très matériel
moi ça dépend des positions en vrai
des fois je me dis ok c'est concret ça
force les choses
mais
c'est vrai que
je préfère généralement attaquer
il a des trucs on dirait qu'il a plus
qu'un pion de plus mais il y en a qu'un
de plus il y a trois qui ont passé en
fait de l'autre côté là et
[Musique]
que ça va être perdu très très vite
c'est pas qui va gagner le match mais
quel joueur ou joueuse de l'équipe de
Gotham va apporter le point décisif
le premier est plutôt ça
terminer la partie
alors après ça va peut-être pas
abandonner non plus en face parce qu'on
sait que n'importe quel abandon c'est
terminé mais
je te reprends ici priori
et après je prends là et je gagne là là
j'ai trop peu ça va trop vite
ça va trop vite fous des 6 c'est un coup
brillant
de l'ordinateur
c'est joli j'ai tout reprend ici pour
les quatre sur quatre il va faire 4/4 là
il va me faire
pour certainement la victoire des Gotham
Knights et du coup ça suffit pour gagner
le match quand un joueur qui fait 4 sur
4 7 mais plutôt bien c'est ouf là je
pense c'est terminé est-ce que tu fais
le G6 G7 peut-être pas sur un G6
d'apprendre des trois j'ai cette dame
n'est pas obligé de donner ce que vous
êtes trois après
j'ai raté il y a plus d'échecs derrière
d'un mecs
et que je vais quand même il peut jouer
de 3
ouais mais j'arrive à fond faire la
course de Dakar c'est bien connu qui
court plus vite
échec et dame là qui a l'air de de
gagner en force ainsi que tous les trois
je peux pas essayer
donc j'ai 6 soit c'est abondant et prise
ok garde échec là du coup il prend le
pion là il va revenir là-haut
et après l'échec là-haut
il va juste peut-être mettre une dame
pour contrer la diagonale noire aussi
là là
et c'est fini c'est pas fini il est
encore ça oui je pensais que j'avais
échec et derrière en fait
où il y a le moins d'échec peut-être
il a 3 cases de la dame et en plus le
pion blanc il fait dame sur l'échec donc
dans tous les cas tu crois beaucoup plus
vite
maintenant je trouve ouais c'est encore
il serait beau qu'il prenne la ville
[Musique]
quand j'ai dit mais vu que je me dis que
tu lisais pas normalement moi
qui apporte officiellement le pont de la
victoire
qui s'impose donc ouais allez on va voir
la fin du match quand même ah il y a un
gars qui est parti ça m'a tout cassé
ton clan il a fait combien
toutes mes trucs je suis désolé les
joueurs qui ont qui ont qui ont quitté
le
colis
il a gagné la première mais après
pour l'instant il est à
il y a un et demi sur trois et demi sur
4 alors qui était premier échiquier donc
forcément
pour votre première échiquet faire une
mise sur quatre pas la moyenne c'est dur
derrière
moi j'ai fait d'Oss contre
OK
Robson qui joue fait de ça
j'ai vraiment fait n'importe quoi je
suis désolé pas grave
il y a une dame de plus mais contre tofu
on dirait quand même être gagnant pour
les Noirs ça
c'est dommage pour les licornes si
Robson c'est quand même une belle
performance ici
j'avais tout bien fait mais en fait oui
voilà les joueurs quittent les zooms et
du coup en fait ça m'a tout changé donc
du coup la caméra était bien mise au
début mais après ça m'a tout changé
parce que
donc du coup voilà pas de souci alors
surtout
le roi va pouvoir s'échapper en Hachette
en G6 il y avait pas de maths c'était
pas si grave
ah ça joue vraiment pour du beurre parce
que la différence de
points enfin le Gola RH chaque compte
pas à une petite messe de natte bien bar
Louis tour à chute
et le seul cours pour parler le matin
c'est tout froid et fuite la Tour Noire
qui va revenir en défense coulisser
faire office de bouclier
[Musique]
tours
là il y a contre échec et Matt
échec contre échec et Madame prochain
qui vient de sa partie malheureusement
c'est trop tard
[Musique]
donc là il y a un pion de plus il y a un
cavalier prend G7 avec sur la prise et
on prend le 7 ça a l'air très difficile
pour
ce match sur cette ronde
mais
ça sera pas suffisant dans tous les cas
après on avait vu peut-être que c'était
dur pour Zoé Tang on va aller voir donc
là c'est très très dur pour vous qui
doivent et ici
Zoé alors qui qui a ce pion au final ce
pion qui avance et cette qualité qui est
toujours toujours d'avance aussi qui a
réussi à tenir le choc et
du coup
ça serait rageant
un demi
bien pour les blancs
[Musique]
c'est pas encore terminé mais
ça devrait quand même gagner qu'avec
cinq on prend le 4
pas trop l'idée
[Musique]
elle va gagner du coup avec les Blancs
c'est pas fait il reste pas beaucoup de
temps mais
c'est bien on va sur quasiment
je dirais mon chat parce qu'il me saoule
et il a gagné un Christian
donc ça va peut-être se terminer
finalement parce que hyper serré
et finalement c'est ça la politique le
matériel est en train de payer
au détriment les initiative
donc
ça commence à être difficile il y a
toujours un pion pour la qualité mais il
y a plus de jeux tu vois ok tu peux
quand même essayer de verrouiller tu
mets un fonds
à deux roues en plus ici peut-être le
roi était mieux là-haut mais elle veut
quand même passer par par ici
il reste que les filles du coup qui joue
pour l'honneur et ça risque de faire du
coup victoire de Tang ce qui serait à
éviter de nuit à 7,5 la remontada qui
était presque là il aurait fallu que que
chancelante finalement
[Musique]
et au final on voit que le score du
match c'est d'être un point donc c'est
vraiment là-dessus après c'est pas
encore fait là
mais quand même le roi qui coinçait sur
la bande
des réseaux de maths
donc il peut encore se passer mais on va
menacer un mode de l'escalier là
peut-être
tout rouge c'est pas laquelle
avait été plus en difficulté peut-être
dans le contenu que son adversaire ouais
mais elle a fait c'est elle qui est
parti échanger la qualité tout ça
franchement moi j'avais bien ce qu'elle
avait fait avec les mains
il faut garder le pion et ça va être
perdu vous qui va partir en plus elle
peut donner encore ce pion elle est tour
échec B5
et c'est complètement perdu
il va y avoir ça sur mon attention la
tour
faut la toucher
plus maintenant
3D 5 B6
c'est facile le roi
ça va être l'abandon
en fait au final c'était hyper serré tu
vois bon avant ce dernier set ça n'était
pas mais au final il y a eu trois-1 et
puis et puis ils ont pas vraiment
transpiré tu vois les Gotham Knights
parce que Nakamura il a envie de gagner
mais ça aurait pu ça aurait pu être plus
chaud que ça en fait cette histoire donc
donc voilà
du coup la semaine prochaine on va voir
du coup d'autres matchs de protester
encore une fois
encore un petit peu
de voir tout ça et donc en attendant ben
écoutez je pense qu'on va couper le
stream samedi ouais juste pour vous
vendredi la prochaine Ligue
à 16 à partir de 16h30 ou 19h selon les
matchs
et voilà on verra l'équipe Blitz qui
jouera contre une autre équipe à une
victoire
donc il y a du beau monde on verra ça
puis quand on aura les appareils dans la
semaine on vous le dira voilà
merci en tant que tous sur le chat
d'avoir été présent lors de ce match
merci aussi à 5000 ans compagnie
aujourd'hui et puis ben on vous dit du
coup la semaine prochaine pour encore
plus d'action
donc bonne soirée à tous et puis à très
bientôt
bonne soirée tout le monde ciao ciao